What are you good at? What is
the work that needs doing?
And what brings you joy?
You are most powerful
in your existing roles,
where you already have specialized
knowledge and robustnetworks.
So how might you lean in
to thosetalents?
Can you help your town, company,
church or school
charge ahead withclimate solutions?
Because what we need is change in
every sector and in every community.
What are you good at, what
are your areas of expertise?
Think about your skills,
resources andnetworks.
What is the work that needs doing?
Are there particular climate and
justice solutions that you're keen on?
What brings you joy or satisfaction?
This is thelong haul.
So it's critical to avoidburnout.
Choose things that enliven you.
Find your role if you haven’t already,
encourage others to find theirs.